je t'explique mon froc tu prends une
tombe tu prends n'importe laquelle 7
octobre est la plus grande
bon après une tonte oignies prennent
tout va choper le tonga lé nom passe à
l'aller trouvez vous mettez en position
de tournant le grand gagnant tournant me
rencontrera donc attester que la côte et
dirait que ça répond benjamin ouais bah
oui on voit tranquille et minervois
temps bien et moi oui il aimait chanter
les gens luttent et l'humilité
non mais oh ça va pas bien aller c'était
un mauvais pour la verrouiller auxquels
il a accès attention mais c'est terminé
pour les très bons trop vers la montée
attendue avec les autres dans la peur du
génial champion olympique non mais oh
ben haim éliminé mana
allez on y va il reste gilles isabelle
géraldine caddie
toualy nom isabelle éliminés ils sont
plus que ça non plus rang trois
bâtiments km h aux halles et méchant
je suis dégoûté attention amis il reste
deux fils de garçon qui va gagner
oui keilwitz élima les gérants du cerf
géraldine tu sers attention on est
toutefois qu'aider géraldine ça joue
très bien la belle attention c'est la
finale on enlève le dit ce qui nous
plaît alors entre vous en un point et
après je rencontre le gagnant et je vous
dis que ce qu'est ce qui va moins autant
à point
[Musique]
géraldine c'est très simple si vous me
battais way en deux points je vous le
dis oui je mettrai le slip de camping
pendant toute l'émission
d'accord on joue bas je choisirais
quelqu'un qui va pourtant le slip de
camping pendant toute l'émission
d'accord j'ai déjà une petite idée et ce
entre les avenues
ça joue clairement que la règle alors
est-ce qu'on fait deux points d'écart et
demi et l'autre comme au bâton
attention balle de match j'ai gagné tony
mme baki sony qui tu veux tu as ta la
musique ouais je sais ça m'a jamais
[Applaudissements]
badama castaldi tu vas te préparer mon
chéri tu reviens dans un instant vous
voulez qu'on fasse rentrer bientôt avec
toi toi dix mois pour lui voilà merci
badri
[Applaudissements]
on dirait vraiment maîtres nageurs sur
la mairie mais c'est que ça te va y
perdre bien sûr bien sûr retrouver ton
style toi peut-être que tu veux je peux
peut-être je rentre un peu le vendre
benjamin a obligé